back here at home the countdown is on
clark county school district students
head back to class
in less than a week on monday today the
school district hosted a back to school
kickoff highlighting a number of
initiatives
that have to do with learning during the
pandemic one of those addresses
plunging grades data shows that nearly
51 percent of middle school students
received at least one f last semester
that's more than double what it was
the previous year superintendent dr
jesus jarrah says every student will
take an assessment once they're back in
the classroom
i you know have the full confidence in
our teachers that they'll be able to
address some of those gaps
this is not going to be something that's
going to be solved in one year you know
this is going to be something that's
going to be multiple years you know so
the summer acceleration may continue you
know and we're going to look at all
these different options for the next
three years
dr jarrah also addressed other
initiatives including grading reform
plans for new pilot schools and creating
a college and career readiness program
later this week we hope you'll join us
here on channel 8 for our back to school
special we've been doing our homework it
airs this thursday at 6 30 pm
we're talking everything you need to
know as your kids head back to the
classroom